viele youtuber reagieren in letzter zeit
auf videos die solche titel tragen wie
beispielsweise after watching des video
uk jackpot oder selena gomez oder posten
oder keine ahnung was ich dachte man
allerdings dass ich heute auf einem
video reagiere was heißt des video maybe
you love justin bieber also scheiß auf
den ganzen hält und so wir schauen uns
heute ein video an nachdem ihr angeblich
justin bieber lieben sollen news geht
feel free to subscribe da ist ja erst
mal aber da wir sehen wir justin bieber
mit einer gitarre an einem pool am meer
oh mein gott ich gar nicht weiter gucke
ich liebe ihn jetzt schon hier läuft er
in der antarktis oder wo auch immer das
ist gegen die durchs wasser wie kanada
überhaupt laufen das ist doch das ist
doch ein mehr after he kissed her hier
auktion ist 5000 dollar und ebay zoll
verbaut
danach liebe ich ihn nicht das ist
einfach nur einfach nur traurig also
justin bieber hat sich seine haare
abgeschnitten und hat die bei ebay
eingestellt für 12.000 dollar das ist
wie so liebich justin bieber denn jetzt
die wurden allerdings nicht für 12.000
dollar verkauft sondern für 40.000 ob er
das gespendet hat weiß man jetzt nicht
hier sehen wir ein bild von justin
bieber und ich glaube das ist normal in
der ecke ja genau hier sehen wir justin
auf einer s-klasse glaube ich posieren
warum sollen mich diese fotos davon
überzeugen ihn zu lieben aber wir
schauen mal weiter hier weiter sein 21
geburtstag mit irgendwelchen topmodels
und so bekommt ihr so ein auto und seine
fette torte niveaus von slade konzert in
salt lake city utah because i was
sitting here it girl in the hospital das
ist süß aber auf der anderen seite hat
er wahrscheinlich tausende von menschen
warten lassen aber das ist auf jeden
fall die neueste aktion wenn dass dieses
mädchen hier war ich weiß es nicht genau
aber dann war es auf jeden fall echt ne
coole aktion
da können schon mal tausende leute
warten hier steht justin schon wieder an
irgendeinem
pool an dem mehr und da sind auch berge
oder so keine ahnung wo das jetzt
irgendwie ist das feld wieder aus hier
liegt er mit irgendeinem wieder mit
einem model oder so aufregend acht
runden liegen die wiederum wieder mit
irgendeinem topmodel hier rechts und
hier liegen kinder da liegt justin hier
steht der jeremy bieber his vater ist
die firma m 11 1 ab da cabañas sind doch
nur lieben versteht mich nicht falsch
ich glaube ihr kennt meine art wie ich
auf sachen direkte und das ist manchmal
ein bisschen hoch nehme aber alles auf
einer ironischen basis also ich mag
justin bieber total gern ohne spaß zeit
mit interviews von dem angeguckt ich
glaube das ist ein mensch der sehr
humble ist der auf jeden fall down to
earth ist der magath soll ich noch mehr
englisch reden also er wirkt so als wär
echt ein sehr sehr sehr sehr lieber
mensch und ich würde mich echt
unglaublich gerne einfach mit ihm
unterhalten also das ist video hier soll
überhaupt nicht irgendwie kritisieren
oder hätten oder so aber wir schauen
jetzt mal weiter und gucken ob wir ihn
noch lieben lernen also sein vater war
früher ein mm weiter hier liegt justin
und bekommt von irgendeinem model
trauben gefüttert oder irgendwie sowas
eno hate aber warum soll ich dann nach
justin bieber lieben hier macht er
glaube ich irgendwelche bedürftigen
arbeiten und errichtet dort vielleicht
eine schule oder irgendwie sowas also
das ist auf jeden fall ganz coole läuft
er wieder mit irgendwelchen freundin
oberkörper frei rum durch die sonne an
pools und so und lebt das highlight hier
steht er am meer
es sieht so ein bisschen so aus wie
diese dingens in teneriffa
aber hier steht ab various videos auf
dem single tuner und songs und youtube
xing ist ident die storage superstar dan
also seine mutter hat videos von ihm auf
youtube hochgeladen das wissen wir denke
ich alle weil dadurch wurde justin
bieber durch asche entdeckt und geräumt
und so weiter und so fort aber warum
soll ich den
hier steht justin mit irgendwelchen
kindern eventuell in ich weiß nicht wo
ich ist dass indien oder so denke ich
mal so anhand den leuten nicht zu
beurteilen hier spielt er mit ihm
irgendwas oder gibt ihm keine ahnung
eine zigarette oder irgendwie sowas hier
hängt er mit irgendeinem flamingo neben
einem pool rum oder so dann sehen wir
hier fette bäume hier vor dem spiel der
fußball mit irgendwelchen andere justin
bieber in düsseldorf fußball spielen da
war ich sogar auch gerade in düsseldorf
also ja coole story oder cars have
caused ab zu 750 dollar an gossip ab
justin bieber gibt pro haarschnitt 750
dollar aus das ist der grund ihn zu
lieben hier sitzt justin noch
irgendeiner bank an seinem handy und
hört musik hier vorne erzählt er sein
ganzes geld zusammen mit irgendwem keine
ahnung was und sie schauen sich ihr geld
dann und am goldketten um hier ja hier
gibt justin einer obdachlosen geld und
das ist wirklich die erste aktion neben
dem vielleicht okay er hat ein kind im
krankenhaus besucht und hat er diese
bedürftigen arbeit ein bisschen leise
dass die erste aktion moment wirklich
nicht okay justin ist ein ganz normaler
mensch und er ist eigentlich ganz nett
aber wie gesagt verstehe mich da bitte
nicht falsch ich bin überhaupt nicht
irgendwie zu helfen
hier fährt er mit wer ist das david
hasselhoff oder so hat es jetzt gerade
nicht so genau erkennen wer das ist so
dass dieser eine schauspieler da der
jetzt der zeit diese krassen locken da
irgendwie hat hier spielt justin bieber
alles und wir haben wieder einen neuen
text freunde harry potter daniel
radcliffe todorovic first impression of
beatles musical the lost thing the
teenage warum soll man da nach justin
bieber lieben tory aber das macht
wirklich keinen sinn hier spielt jetzt
basketball tier ist auch wegen seinem
roller
hier sind irgendwelche fans und er
versucht sich irgendwie in den bus zu
retten
hier vorne stellte der gerade dann hier
auch edward kostet 5000 zu 10.000 dollar
to have just amazing richard pott der
partie ja da wird uns noch mal gezeigt
wie teuer justin bieber eigentlich ist
ich meine das bild ist ganz schön das
wird es vor allem auch in köln
das ist
unter dem titel justin bieber mit einem
affen wir spur noch mal ein bisschen
weiter vor hier macht der love you in
den in den sand hier spielen die mit ein
paar kindern das ist top manager hier
ist ein löwe und justin mal schauen ob
kinect star wars just und ganz cool but
i changed to be 2 wurden gern trouble
das habe ich der hauptstadt male mal
also in deutschland hat man jetzt
natürlich nicht solche noten wie
beispielsweise f dass dann ein sexist
und ein app kann man ja relativ gut
eigentlich zudem b machen aber bei mir
war es auch damals so dass ich klausuren
die nicht gut waren also wenn es alles
was unter befriedigend war habe ich
meiner mutter einfach nicht gezeigt und
habe dann den lehrern immer gesagt ja
die haben es gesehen aber selbst den
nicht gezeigt dass es in der vierten
klasse aufgeflogen und ich habe ein
bisschen ärger bekommen aber ich war
halt irgendwie früher sofort
perfektionistisch also justin hat seine
noten gefälscht das macht mich jetzt
auch nicht dazu dass ich ihn liebe aber
anscheinend das halb normaler mensch
auch ist man hier sitzt mit
irgendwelchen leuten hier sitzt er
wieder an dem see hier ist damit dem
floyd mayweather war da gerade genau
hier ist auch nochmal floyd mayweather
hier steht dem wasserfall hier steht an
da die ringe schon washington lieber
personal laptop gestohlen hours later
some new pictures from twitter claiming
to be just in das ist raus
aber das ist noch lange kein grund warum
ich jetzt sage boah just in der lawi
passiert ja irgendwo keine ahnung in
kanada oder den alpen an irgendeinem
brand allerdings im feuer
hier ist er mit irgendwelchen models mit
ganz vielen models so warum sollte man
ihn danach lieben justin appeared in den
episoden
september 2001
er streichelt er gerade ein tier im zoo
hier hat er seinen laptop anscheinend
dann wieder gefunden
hier hängt da auch drauf hier hat er
irgendwelche guinness weltrekorde in der
hand hier vorne ist auf irgendeinem bot
drauf dann hat er hier vorne täter mit
martin garrigues freunde martin
garrigues ist die nächste person der
welt ich guck mir halt voll gern so
interviews anfang irgendwie drake von
selena gomez von justin von martin
garrigues von postillon von einfach
irgendwie solchen international
bekannten all stars und sternchen und
martin garrigues ohne spaß in interviews
und so wirkt sowie der netteste
freundlichste liebste mensch den es
irgendwie gibt also hier hängt justin
mit martin garrigues irgendwo in
amsterdam ab dann haben wir als nächstes
foto justin bieber hier auf einem
golfplatz wo er versucht ein paar hole
in ones zu schlagen hier steht er in
irgend einem supermarkt das wurde
gefilmt von wie hollywood dann haben wir
vorne justin bieber mit bodyguards am
shoppen wenn wir weiter durchlebten
wirtschaftsteam wie man mit
fußballprofis man das ist ich liebe
justin bieber wenn wir ein bisschen
weiter durch ägypten sehen wir ihnen
hier rum chillen mit keine ahnung ist es
lewis hamilton ich weiß es nicht genau
hängen hier im bett hier ist er mit
floyd mayweather am 10
wenn wir weiter durchgehend hängt ja
hier mit irgendwelchen models auf hier
ist dann mit einem delfin hier hängt er
auf irgendeinem gemieteten keine ahnung
was yacht mit irgendeinem model hier
fordere auch schon wieder und sie macht
ein foto von ihm hier vorne hängt damit
freunden und die zocken einfach
irgendwie uno oder keine ahnung
irgendwie was ich glaube texte kommen
jetzt gar nicht mehr so wirklich da
hängt auch tempel serien mit rum hier
ist wieder neymar ist und messi hier
posiert justin in seinem bugatti veyron
dann haben wir hier justin rumhängen mit
keine ahnung wem hier hängt er mit cd
thommes am sonnen
hier ist auf irgend einer pool party und
das war's also wie wollen wir das ganze
denn jetzt zusammen fassen ich habe mir
dieses video des make you love justin
bieber video wirklich nur ausgesucht
weil ich dachte okay viele leute
reagieren in letzter zeit auf videos von
wegen ja nach diesem video hast du diese
personen dann kommen sofort viele
skandale und dass die leute abgezogen
haben und ich habe mir gedacht ich mach
das anders und das ihr seht wie nett
auch menschen sein können obwohl viele
sachen über die verbreitet werden und
das einzige was ich jetzt erfahren aber
über justin bieber ist dass seine
haarschnitte so an die tausend euro
kosten
dass er im weltraum fährt mit topmodels
schild das er damals bei einer csi folge
mit dabei war dass es bis zu 10.000
dollar kostet justin bieber zu mieten
für eine stunde singen und das sind
alles negative fakten er oder wie würdet
ihr das jetzt beurteilen falls ihr
allerdings andere videos so in die
richtung kennt vielleicht auch mal ein
hass video ich weiß nicht ich mag es
eigentlich nicht so gern deswegen will
ich darauf ungern reagieren aber wenn es
echt komische menschen sind so dann kann
man das schon mal machen dann schreibt
mir diese videos gerne in die kommentare
und jetzt freunde an alle die jetzt
gerade noch dran sind ihr bekommt den
ersten einblick in ein merchandiser ist
die sein was in meinem shop kommen wird
am 16
da das ist ein motiv was eine finnische
zeichnerin für uns gezeichnet hat lc rwe
für luca und dann so eine explosion mit
dem smiley und mit spitzer mit einem
alpaka dritten sind dinge die ich
einfach mag die für mich stehen so ein
bisschen das packen wir auf dem t-shirt
hinten oder vorne drauf da überlegen wir
grad noch weil entweder hinten und vorne
dann noch einen kleinen schriftzug hier
vorne oder halt direkt vorne auf jeden
fall ist das so dass erste merchandise
design was ich euch jetzt hier
präsentieren werde
wir haben noch viele weitere designs ein
design ist noch ein bisschen ich weiß
noch nicht ob ich raus hauen aber es
weder es wird auf jeden fall krass wir
machen uns heftige gedanken gerade die
kollektion lounge am 16 also sind noch
drei monate hin ich wollte schon mal
sagen und schon mal so ein bisschen
ankündigen aber jetzt meine damen und
herren will ich das video an der stelle
ist aber auch beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gerne mal ein leichter
und jetzt ja würde ich eigentlich nur
noch sagen